[Musik]
es war ein angriff auf die amerikanische
infrastruktur vor knapp zwei wochen
russischer hacker hatten die wichtigste
pipeline des landes lahmgelegt lange
schlangen vor den tankstellen an der us
ostküste die software die für die
attacke benutzt wurde greift nur
computersysteme haben die nicht große
sprachig sind vor allem im westen das
ist eine zerstörerische mindestens eine
zersetzende attacke gegen die kritische
infrastruktur der usa von der mehrere
zehn millionen menschen betroffen
das geht schon seit jahren so
die russische regierung gibt es für mich
keinen zweifel
sie hat diese entwicklung zugelassen und
steht im einklang mit dem strategischen
ziel der die stabilisierung und
einschüchterung dass die russische
regierung verfolgt christopher crepes
waffeln cyber sicherheit zuständiger
direktor im us department of homeland
security eine position die geschaffen
wurde nachdem die us geheimdienste 2017
zu dem schluss gekommen waren dass
russland eine massive operation zur
beeinflussung der us wahl durchgeführt
hat
wir waren nicht so sehr besorgt über den
einen möglichen computer heck sondern
dass jemand die köpfe der menschen act
des informationskampagnen gesteuert aus
china iran und ganz besonders russland
verbreitet über die sozialen medien
seien die größte gefahr für den
demokratischen prozess vor allem
russland würde damit ein klares ziel
verfolgen sie wollen spaltung und chaos
sie profitieren davon wenn wir im
vergleich zu ihnen schlecht aussehen
krabs selbst republikaner wird von
donald trump im vergangenen november mit
einem tweet gefeuert nachdem er die
wahlen und ihren ausgang für sicher
erklärt hat jobs behauptung die wahlen
seien gestohlen worden sei ein geschenk
für alle feinde der amerikanischen
demokratie
es gibt nicht einen der riesen vorwurf
stützt und doch wiederholt in der
ehemalige präsident permanent das futter
zu oder sind dieser nicht fakten
basieren realität mehrere zehn millionen
menschen dieser lüge wonach die wahlen
gestohlen waren
wir sind in einem vorort von washington
dc haben uns verabredet mit einem mann
der viel zu erzählen hat wir treffen uns
in einem hotelzimmer zum ersten mal
spricht er im deutschen fernsehen
bevor ich nach amerika kam war ich
offizier im ersten direktorat des kgb
dem auslandsgeheimdienst
ich habe in der americas abteilung
gearbeitet die die operationen in den
usa und kanada überwacht und geleitet
juli schwetzler major des kgb hatte
zusammen mit wladimir putin am juli &
drop auf institut der sowjetischen
geheimdienstes studiert nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion geht er
1993 in die usa arbeitet heute als
privater ermittler für große
internationale unternehmen und er hat
vor dem us-kongress über russische
geldwäsche aus gesagt wir würden uns
heute in einem neuen kalten krieg
befinden einem kalten krieg 2.0 in
russland gegen den westen führen würde
sagt schwarz im klassischen kalten krieg
waren die waffen atombomben und
raketentests
heute sind es subversive operationen
active matches und der versuch die
länder von innen heraus zu brechen und
besonders wichtig dabei ist die
korruption der westlichen politischen
elite das deutsche beispiel war
historisch gesehen das erste sie nennen
es die schröder-regierung der ehemalige
kgb-agent spielt damit auf bundeskanzler
gerhard schröder an
hier zu sehen bei der eröffnung der nord
stream-pipeline zusammen mit wladimir
putin ehemaligen stasi agenten matthias
warnig und dem mächtigen vorsitzenden
des russischen gazprom konzerns alexej
miller
in den letzten tagen seiner amtszeit
2005 hatte schröder den vertrag zum bau
der nord stream pipeline unterzeichnet
um kurz darauf vorsitzender der nord
stream ag zu werden
kanzler schröder hat den job angenommen
wurde so zum angestellten von gazprom
gazprom ist sowas wie das portemonnaie
des kreml
der größte politische erfolg aber von
dem in russland niemand zu träumen
gewagt hatte ging auf eine operation des
kgb anfang der 80er jahre zurück donald
trump wurde rekrutiert mit einer
kombination aus geld und psychologischen
faktoren der psychologische faktor war
in diesem fall sehr wirksam
denn da war jemand mit einem recht
niedrigen iq gepaart mit aufgeblasenen
eitelkeit und nazismus
das ist eine tödliche kombination das
ist der traum eines jeden
geheimdienstoffiziers der nach
potenziellen rekruten aus schauen oder
dem vorwand am roten platz
möglicherweise hat trump tower bauen zu
können wird schon nach moskau eingeladen
nach seinen gesprächen kehrt er nach new
york zurück und schaltet in drei großen
tageszeitungen eine ganzseitige anzeige
der amerikas bündnisverpflichtungen
scharf kritisiert juli schweiz der sich
zu diesem zeitpunkt für ein paar monate
in der kgb zentrale auf welt fällt eine
depesche der kollegen aus new york in
die hände
ich habe die depesche der auswertung
gesehen denn ich war an einer parallel
operation beteiligt es war der traum des
kgb es wurde von der abteilung einfluss
operationen als eine der größten und
erfolgreichsten einfluss operationen
seit vielen jahren gesehen
fuß zu fassen einen dollar und jede
menge steuererleichterungen übernimmt er
das heruntergewirtschaftete commodore
hotel für die sanierung der zimmer
benötigt der 200 neue fernseher und er
wendet sich an einen kleinen
elektronikladen in midtown manhattan
der laden gehörte zwei jüdischen
immigranten aus der sowjetunion einer
von der den laden manager war kgb angeht
ich habe zu dieser zeit in washington in
der station des kgb gearbeitet und ich
weiß dass das unser laden der laden
macht in den 80er jahren schlagzeilen
weil er bekannt dafür ist dass seine
kunden hauptsächlich aus der sowjetunion
kommen das einzukaufen was es in der
kommunistischen sowjetunion nicht gibt
fernsehgeräte vor allem jeder
sowjetbürger der in den usa gearbeitet
jeder besucher hochrangige beamte
minister mussten in diesen laden
es war so etwas wie eine verpflichtungen
diesen laden zu gehen und die geräte
dort zu kaufen um sie nach moskau zu
bringen der kgb hatte große sorge das
fbi oder cia die geräte verwandten
elektronische einrichtungen einbauen und
ein mächtiger kreml minister dann das
gerät nach hause bringt oder in seinem
büro installiert und die amerikaner
mithören können weil die geräte aber mit
zwei empfang system ausgestattet sind
damit sie auch in der sowjetunion
funktionieren sind sie etwa 30 prozent
teurer als herkömmliche geräte der
donald trump machte es gar keinen sinn
30 extra zusammen aber für den
ladenbesitzer wenn er denn ein echter
geschäftsmann gewesen wäre und nicht für
den kgb gearbeitet hätte würde es keinen
sinn machen donald trump einen 30
prozent discount zu gehen also nutzte
der kgb die gelegenheit um die fernseher
zu verwanzen und sie finanzierten einen
teil des deals mit
das war der beginn der kultivierung der
zielperson
die kgb agenten in new york sammeln
informationen über donald trump
analysieren sein charakter und seine
schwächen und empfehlen ihn schließlich
der zentrale in moskau
unter dem vorwand am roten platz
möglicherweise ein trump tower bauen zu
können lockt der kgb trump nach moskau
um herauszufinden ob er sich für eine
zusammenarbeit eignen würde
[Musik]
wir haben seine eitelkeit und seinen
narzissmus genutzt um dieses lächerliche
unrealistische angebot zu unterbreiten
das war völliger irrsinn
denn der eiserne vorhang stand noch und
der grund war ja gerade dass die
sowjetbürger nicht sehen sollten wir die
menschen im westen leben
[Musik]
das letzte was der kreml wollte war ein
glitzernder trump tower gleich neben dem
lenin mausoleum am roten platz
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
mit donald trump von russland nicht aus
den augen gelassen er macht geschäfte
mit russischen gangstern und oligarchen
mit den besten beziehungen in den kreml
als er 2016 für die präsidentschaft
kandidiert führen die russischen
geheimdienste eine massive operationen
durch um ihn zum präsidenten zu machen
jobs war sie seit der jackpot für die
russische führung gewesen habe die usa
verändert es erinnert mich an eine kopie
dessen was wir in moskau sehen wo
wahrheit demokratische werte
menschenrechte und gerechtigkeit keine
rolle spielen das einzige was zählt sind
geld macht und ein zynismus regiert die
politische welt
das mit donald trumps wahlniederlage
alles vorbei sein
daran glaubt juli schweiz nicht die
russen werden versuchen ihn weiter wie
einen der ihren zu behandeln
er ist ihr menschliches kapital und sie
werden versuchen es maximal einzusetzen
so lange es geht
aus meiner sicht bei einer solchen
operation werden sie ihnen nutzen
solange es möglich ist um dieses land
von innen heraus zu brechen
solche russischen einfluss operationen
aber seien nicht nur auf die usa
begrenzt
auch deutschland müsse in diesem
wahljahr mit russischen operationen und
des informationskampagnen rechnen
denn für russland stehe viel auf dem
spiel für die russen ist deutschland das
wichtigste land in europa und nutzt nun
zwei ist ihr wichtigstes projekt
ein abbruch des projekts wäre für das
gegenwärtige regime ein desaster
die möglichkeit dass die grünen gewinnen
treibt diese tage den kreml um
denn die grünen sind erklärte gegner von
nord stream 2 deutschland solle sich
vorbereiten könne von den letzten us
waren eine menge lernen meint chris
capps das bei den vergangenen wahlen
hier in den usa neu war sind die
behauptungen dass die wahlen selbst
angegriffen wurden
es sei manipuliert und gestohlen worden
falsche stimmzettel das sind die punkte
die sie attackiert haben um das
vertrauen zu erschüttern
besonders gefährlich aber werde es wenn
desinformation und innere zersetzung von
denen kommt die einheit geleistet haben
die demokratie zu verteidigen gegen ihre
feinde von innen und von außen
[Applaus]